- Is it kind of like, the whole scene,
is it kind of bittersweet
that it's coming to an end?
- Definitely, mostly it's
sad because I can't stalk
Ted Danson any more, every
summer, although will it stop me?
No.
(laughter)
But we end the show so beautifully,
and it's so rare that
the creators get a chance
to make the call on when you say goodbye.
Normally, a network just pulls the plug,
and so it's amazing to have
planned this year in advance
and soak up all of what
makes it beautiful.
And it's such a good ending,
everyone's gonna cry,
no one's gonna be okay.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] It's awesome.
I love crying.
- [Jamel] We're all doomed.
- So I can't believe I
found out this is actually,
The Good Place is your first acting job,
'cause you, I know you were
hosting in England before,
but this is your first,
that's a hell of a first job.
- I didn't sleep with anybody to get this.
(audience clapping and cheering)
(laughter)
- Did you say I didn't sleep
with anyone? (laughing)
- I didn't sleep with anyone to get this,
if anything that would've lost me the job.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, I
would hang out with you.
- I'm not great.
(laughter)
- That was awesome.
- The audition was my
first ever time acting,
and so I went in, and I think
maybe because I was so sure
I wouldn't get the job, I had
that kind of reckless abandon,
of just a maniac on the loose,
and he took that as confidence,
which was a mistake, and gave me the job.
- Which was a mistake.
- Yeah, here I am.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- I love though that you
also promote body positivity,
you have a campaign, a
movement, called I Weigh, right?
- Yeah, it's a body neutrality movement.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- So why is this important to you?
- So, I Weigh is a body
neutrality movement,
it's about getting away from
thinking about your body
and instead, thinking about
the things in your life
that you should be grateful for,
like, I weigh the sum off all my parts,
I weigh, like, you can't measure my worth
on a weighing scale, you can't
measure your own like that.
It's insane that we still do this to women
in this day and age.
So it's about, you know,
I weigh my relationship,
my contribution to society,
my financial independence,
my activism.
That's what I weigh, that's my worth,
and so it's a movement thing.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- That is very cool.
- And it's this whole global movement
where we have almost a million followers
and we get five or 6000 more a day
if people from everywhere,
from all walks of life,
who are just tired of being
undermined and underestimated
by society, and it's this
really beautiful space,
that I'm launching into
a company next year
and we're gonna take
this as far as we can.
And we're changing laws,
and changing global policies together,
and we're just done
with how we treat women.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- I think it's important,
because I think sometimes
we focus so much on the aesthetics
of what health looks like
instead of actual health,
and what's going on inside your body,
and we just don't know, you know?
So it's like, what's going
on in someone's life,
so I think it's a really
important thing you're doing,
especially 'cause you have
such a big spotlight on you,
so thank you for doing that.
- Thanks.
Thanks.
You've been through some
body shaming before.
- I have no idea what you're
referring to (laughs).
I literally am getting
trolled right now, online.
- That's so wild,
but I remember you going through that
and then very shortly afterwards
I gained a lot of weight
back in England, I was
a radio DJ by the way,
you couldn't even see me,
people just wanted to know I
was thin over the airwaves,
so I got nationally fat
shamed for six months
in my own country, and it
was your response to yours
that gave me the strength
to get through mine.
- Did I use a word that
I can't say on this show?
- [Jamel] Yeah (laughs).
- Yeah.
It is a great campaign though,
and thank you so much for doing it.
It's important, like I said,
'cause you've a spotlight,
it's important for all
of us who have spotlights
to do something really cool,
outside of our egocentric lives, you know?
You can catch Jamel though,
hosting the series The
Misery Index, Tuesdays on CBS
and also watch her in the final
episode of The Good Place,
Thursdays on NBC.